just 24 hours after network president
jeff zucker's resignation all eyes seem
to be zeroing in on now ousted cnn
anchor chris cuomo
an internal meeting that went on was
incredibly tense there was a lot of
anger in the room
the two consenting adults what's the
problem there
we're getting to a game of thrones level
of infighting at this point at cnn
according to fox news contributor joe
koncha that internal meeting was
attended by cnn's top anchors
questioning cuomo's role in zucker's
resignation dana bash says that the
punishment didn't meet the crime jake
tapper is now comparing chris cuomo to a
terrorist here's tapper quote he
threatened jeff zucker jeff sucker said
we don't negotiate with terrorists and
chris cuomo blew the place up it's been
widely speculated cuomo's legal team
raised the issue of jeff and alison
gallis undisclosed romance after they
fired him last december chris cuomo's
role here is a pivotal one his lawyers
according to insiders are now saying
that the relationship between zucker and
gullis was improper and they should not
have been able to decide what happened
to chris cuomo's career cuomo's team is
not commenting but a source familiar
with the situation tells e.t he is not
responsible for jeff's resignation
hot mess
the other big question when did jeff and
allison's romance start allison claims
it began during covent former cnn anchor
soledad o'brien calls that quote amusing
tweeting it was an open secret and i
haven't even worked there for like eight
years they're saying the relationship
started during covid well
is that accurate if it started before
then which is what the allegations are
by many many people in the industry that
her promotions may have been directly
related to their affair
she started out as a as a publicist and
now she's the executive vice president
at cnn in her memoir going there former
colleague katie couric said she felt
uncomfortable by their close
relationship nearly 10 years ago while
launching her abc talk show jeff made a
huge push to bring on alison gallus they
were joined at the hip and it made me
really uncomfortable on november 29th
jeff was named president of cnn his
first hire alison gallis today katie
released a new statement saying quote
i've wondered about the nature of their
relationship it seems their colleagues
and the media at large turned a blind
eye to inappropriate behavior